In the last lesson,
what I provided was actually a simplistic comparison between HL7 v2 and v3 messages.
We will now look at that in more detail to help us understand
the evolution of HL7 standards development.
HL7 v2 is not plug and play.
In fact, the concept was just getting started back then.
In the hardware world, it certainly was not very common.
V2 provides 80% of the interface and
a framework to negotiate the remaining 20% on a case-by-case basis.
Thus, developing a v2 interface between
any two systems requires coding and has a certain degree of customization.
Part of the reason why is that v2 is not based on a standard model.
The key goal of HL7 v3 development was to get as close to plug and play as possible.
It uses the Reference Information Model,
or RIM, in an effort to provide consistency across the standard.